all right we have the whole okay did you
guys get all your pp's out this time
yes but there's gonna be more PP okay
all right that's why I went I've been
over hydrating in the mornings
yeah yeah no but I think as we age it's
uh oh no there's no coffee that gets me
because as soon as you have the coffee
that's the only time I feel my age is
like at three in the morning when you
did get up for the stumble to the
you're getting through the night I'm
getting through the night yeah really I
am too but not always but if I wake up
in the middle of the night it's the
terror and the anxiety and all that
stuff but it's not the uh it's not the
people the terror creeping it's not the
pp you can't pee that out
[Laughter]
[Music]
well guys here we are Randall Randall
we've been watching episodes from season
five and every single one of them have
been directed by you and they're all
fantastic they really are man and we
thought we'd better we better get ran on
the pods so the fans can hear directly
from him
how brilliant we are yes yeah mostly we
wanted you here to talk about reinforce
that speak of our greatness and tell it
across the lands
um I think the secret is just standing
out of your way no not at all you know
true that is what we thought the secret
was to
um for some time and then you kind of
came in and you really kind of pushed us
a little bit it's something we've been
talking about you know you pushed us to
be a little bit more ambitious and you
know you would you would push back in a
way that that you know didn't get our
hairs up and got us like listening to
you you know you got to do some some
kind of bigger stuff which I think was
really helpful and good and I think
there's more of that we were discussing
how when you came in we we
I think it was a combination of you and
Jackman but around that time the two of
you guys took what we were doing and
pushed it into uh just push the limits
of what we could do and episodes could
be bigger and we could get out of the
sort of bar and apartments and we could
have a World Series defense episode or
we could you know shoot a hockey puck on
a rink and uh and have some you know
create a stadium that we couldn't afford
to or be allowed to be in yeah uh and so
anyways uh
over the years we found that um bringing
in adults adults to the room have uh
have garnered great results um Wags one
of them
um Randall's one of them Matt shackman
was one of them in some ways Martin
Rozelle even though they're basically
children
too much into something a little bit
more cohesive on a consistent basis they
were more professional in some in some
ways yes in some ways they had more
experience in other rooms whereas we had
not yes to go on and on and on before we
allow you to speak you know I think
it's nice I'm just sitting here not yeah
yeah I think it is like look the
business this particular business is one
of collaborations and you know
oftentimes someone will come to you I
was just watching a like a because I'm
obsessed with watching a thing about
like the making of like uh There Will Be
Blood and you know Daniel Day-Lewis like
sending uh voice memos to Paul Thomas
Anderson he'll be like oh you want to do
that with voice and then warming up to
it same thing with Phil Hoffman and
Boogie Nights where he was like oh well
I'll talk on Earth you know and he was
like I'm not sure but I I like to
collaborate with people there's a reason
I'm working with this person
and I think you were the first person
that we worked with who really was
coming at us from sometimes from an
angle that we weren't seeing and then we
trusted you we said well let's try a few
sort of Randall ways yeah and you sort
of taught us a new way to shoot and
cover the show and I remember him saying
things like You're you can be doing more
with this and not SP you know because
and not have it spend and not spend more
money and more time like you had a what
you were like you you had an ambition
that allowed you to within the
constraints of the budget of the show
and the number of days that we had to
shoot where you were able to get big
things in the same amount of time I
think we also it was when I'm not sure
if you were using three cameras at that
time before I came in I think we were we
were definitely using three cameras at
sometimes yeah uh whereas now I feel
like we have them we have three cameras
like yeah I believe when you came in you
said you should be shooting three
cameras yeah all the time all the time
time yeah why lose anything you know
everybody's doing great stuff and if you
have you know coverage coverage and a
master yeah or you know a way to hand
off to another location why not do that
so yeah can we start from the beginning
let's back it up I want to talk about
your path in because I remember that for
the very first time I met you
um you had just come back from you were
a white water Riverboat guide yeah is
that correct can we talk about I was I
was I was a rafting though yeah
Riverboat right Rough Guide yeah
this is a pretty normal this is a pretty
normal path into the industry so yeah
yeah
explain how they should go learn how to
Whitewater direct to Hollywood yeah no
it's a it's a well-worn path from
whitewater kayaking to directing I mean
Paul Thomas Anderson
on the Waters of the LA River yeah
Stanley Kubrick was also um
Whitewater Enthusiast I was doing I was
a Whitewater raft guide and
um
I started I started uh filming
Expeditions and I started filming I
remember that the raft trips yes now was
this and this is in Australia in
Australia yeah but also like in Papua
New Guinea and other places sure and
then I went and did
um so I was filming those from a kayak
I'd kayak down the Rapids hop out film
the film the rafters come through and
sell them interest sorry in in shooting
you know uh being a director before so
you learned how to use cameras because
you wanted to record your Expeditions
yeah I learned how to use it that's
that's that's exactly right the company
I was doing it for I was leading these
Expeditions so why don't you start
filming it I'm like you mean like with a
camera or something yeah okay can we
even go back even further because now I
I think it's interesting people love to
hear people's Journeys from the
beginning and so how old were you when
you started doing that like what would
happen before that what your interest
lied in adventure sports yeah in in
really in Whitewater
um and and all outdoor extreme sports
you know uh skiing uh hiking you know
sea kayaking mountain biking when you
grow up in like Ohio I did I grew up in
Ohio right yeah where lots of great
white water there as well but yeah I
started I just took off traveling when I
was 18 years old stayed away for
really 23 years and kind of figured out
who I was going to be I got kicked out
of high school which is also the when
you get kicked out of high school that's
a good story
no nothing I'm proud of it was in the
population of things yeah so you were a
rascal and then I was a rascal and a
poor student and so you want to be
outside yeah
but but no
No Visions of
Hollywood directors I still don't know
if I really wanted no I do yeah no I had
never had any designs on this I never
even wanted to be a photographer or you
know a videographer it just happened and
so I started filming it and I'm like I
started really enjoying it and then uh
Mark Burnett came through and I I ended
up getting like some sponsorship for
kayaking because I would go do stupid
things and people could take photos of
me doing stupid this guy's crazy enough
so go over that waterfall with the
camera yeah Mountain Dew so yeah I I I
was doing that and I got a call from a
buddy who's location manager who said
look I need to find
um some River areas so we could do for
this thing called Eco challenge which is
a 500 Mile Wilderness Adventure Race and
that was Mark Burnett's thing before he
did Survivor so I took them on all these
different rivers and showed them you
know some River sections because he
needed him for the race and I said you
know you should hire me to to film it
and uh he did and that that's how I
started filming wow wow now what year
was that
1997. 1997 huh so 97. so when Eco
Challenge and I did seven of those I did
them all over the world great great gig
you know you just off on your own
carrying a heavy camera trying to keep
up with these hardcore Adventure Racers
so I did that for seven years and then
uh by the way was it film like in 97
were you shooting on film no we're
shooting a really really heavy beta
camps oh really heavy yeah yeah I
convinced bernetti should hire me on on
Survivor and I DP'd the first Survivor
and uh
then that's a big deal yeah huge yeah
you were that I don't know that I knew
that you were the DP on the first season
of Survivor yeah and for our fans who
don't know that's the Director of
Photography so that means you're
basically in charge of the cameras and
the lighting and there will be a
director with you but you have a lot to
to say and a lot of input on the look
and and the style yeah well actually
there was no director out there we were
just shooting what happened so the DP
essentially was the director yeah we
were just like you had producers who
were logging with the conversation so
they could build stories uh-huh but in
terms of what we were filming nobody was
telling me what to film where we just
shot what happened you know and it kind
of veritas like documentary style yeah
very much running gun and and just catch
capture as much reality as you can and
uh yeah do you feel like the the
experience of following around a bunch
of Maniacs in an island helped you in
some way when it was filled very
familiar yeah
yeah less asses and elbows I could get
them to face me yeah that was my key to
directing like face me face the camera
yeah according to my research it was
your time on Survivor that um was the
reason that uh you were um pulled into
the office because they wanted that feel
that real reality documentary feel I was
I was in um Jackson Hole so people
always hired me to go do stupid things
with cameras
um and I was filming
um Sean White and Jeremy Jones
um and I was
um have you know I was skiing with them
and filming them and Ben Silverman who
was in the video Village says that's the
guy who should be the DP of the office
like I don't know why he thought that
because I can ski with a camera we know
Ben and he's just a very enthusiastic
and very enthusiastic impulsive but but
that sometimes it takes that right for
someone to have that that kind of vision
to see it yeah to be like why not this
guy yeah I I you know why you would
think you'd take that guy and put him in
a fluorescent lit office I don't know
but Ben saw something I I saw that's the
kind of radical guy we need filming
people now yeah maybe it's that he saw
you skiing while while camera operating
and thought I could get this guy to do
anything yeah yeah yeah he's a he's this
is the same person
now when he when you get that call and
they say hey we'd like you to to direct
how many episodes did they offer you oh
um so I got I was the DP on the
and I DP'd like over 100 episodes and I
met with Greg Daniels and Greg and I got
along really great and really enjoyed
each other's humor and blah blah so we
we
um in filming that show Greg said you're
telling jokes to the camera and I'm like
yeah I'm trying to he says well you
should direct something like okay so
everything really has just happened to
me but what is the designs of my own
there's a big learning curve there
because I I imagine when you're dping
Survivor you're the lighting is
practical right you go into a building
and it's lit like when you're deep in
the office you have a gaffer and you
know a best boy and you're hanging Kino
flows or whatever they're using at the
time and you're in charge of how that
looks so what was the learning curve
there in terms of that was big yeah it
was a big learning pretty much who are
you I remember the first time I was I
started filming something my key my grip
was he grabbed me by the belt I'm like
what are you doing man he's like oh I'm
just making you safe I'm like you don't
I can't see where I'm going when I'm
going backwards that you're there and it
just it just freaked me out it's like
yeah what are you holding me I'm not
gonna yeah this is like you can't touch
certain things that other people can
touch you can't pick up a c-stand you
probably didn't know what a c-stand was
I have many what is that called many
many offenses of doing that okay what
you're alluding to there is it's very
common practice that if a camera
operator is moving backwards there'll be
a grip behind them yeah to make sure
they're making sure they don't fall down
or step over something but what you're
saying is that's the first time anybody
had looked out for your safety
for that you were just walking backwards
or the camera in the jungle in the
jungle so did you do you do any sort of
book learning to try to figure out these
things or did you just it was all onset
experience it was uh it was all onset
experience I kind of think that my
greatest asset is not knowing any better
um because you can actually you know
there are no rules you know thirds I
don't know it looks cool when I put them
in you know doing the interviews on
Survivor I thought it looked interesting
for it to be in Knights rather than and
make the the the the the environment the
character or even maybe what that means
yeah so explain that what it's thirds
and Ninth well you know there's this
this rule of thirds and framing yeah
that it's it's really nice to put split
the fame into thirds that's a very
conventional way of thinking about
framing but on Survivor I thought that
the the
the environment was more as much a
character as the person sitting there um
being interviewed so I played with heavy
foreground elements of you know ants
crawling across a raw lob in the
foreground of a person talking so I
think stuff like that was not knowing
any better it was a very liberating were
you nervous about like matching eye
lines or anything like that but you or
you knew you were going to cross cover
so those things would sort of tie in
automatically you know from filming
observational documentaries and react
and reality the eye line is never in
question you never think about it yeah
you know I mean you're on Survivor and
there's five people in a conversation
and you have two cameras there plus the
boom operators and all of a sudden
somebody over here starts talking and
the line gets crazy so that one of the
operators knows that they need to duck
out of the frame go and get on the other
right side of the frame so you're
constantly adjusting the the the frame
lines so that it doesn't look like
people are talking away from each other
yeah yeah because if you know you want
both people looking looking like they're
talking to each other and if you're on
the wrong side of the line it'll appear
that it does look goofy yeah so that was
a that was a really good skills like I
didn't need to learn that book because I
had to learn it every single day with
all these camera operators and and and
the boom operators and thinking about
that Survivor was boomed there's no
there's no laws on people right and
there's eight people in a tribe who are
all having a conversation you never know
who's going to talk and the whole show
is boomed they're not wearing anything
um
aren't they wearing t-shirts and [__]
like no there are others they're free to
take it off and do whatever okay so
they're yeah I didn't watch a lot of
survivors yeah I mean neither
apparently a lot of people did and
continue to I believe it's still um
I have never seen one episode of
Survivor I have not either season I have
nothing against it I just didn't I just
know this it never came across my radar
I remember it on for 30 years yeah
Burnette pitched it to me and this buddy
of mine is location manager like you
pitched the show to us I'm like that is
the dumbest idea ever nobody's gonna
watch that anyway he was right I was
wrong yeah totally did you think the
same about the office when you heard it
boring why are people I love the British
office yeah well for us though that was
the show that I think made us think we
could make our own show because of the
way it was shot and lit the British
office yeah the British officer because
it the lighting was so practical and
because the cameras were so handheld we
thought well we can all sure we can go
into a room with tiny cameras and
practical lighting that we can do so we
can make something that looks like that
so I think it was a natural I think we
have Evolution for us also trying to
capture the improvisational quality of
like Curb Your Enthusiasm and and it
just felt like the coverage was
far left the coverage and the lighting
were way less important than capturing
performances in the moment capturing you
know uh real conversations moments that
can only happen once because if you try
to turn around on it you're never going
to remember and it's never going to be
the same
you know and so that was a big
inspiration for us like the British
office and curb that's a big reason for
me to want to shoot three cameras yeah
right is that you're never losing any of
that yeah and it and it also I think it
I think when you're shooting with three
cameras it affects the actors tell me
absolutely in a way that then you know
you're on it is the absolute best to to
not have to do your side and then turn
around and do the other side well it's
like you said you know you're if you're
on at the same time as I'm on we're both
on camera then I'm going to get a better
performance you know he's going to get a
better performance for me because I'm on
camera yeah I'm not just going to be off
camera like reading my lines or you know
however there are limitations to that
aesthetic right and I'm sure you've now
moved on to shooting all sorts of
different ways so I'm sure you've worked
on shows where you've had to like set
the camera and then turn around and do a
whole very different Fargo yeah yeah you
know it was just really One camera well
the Cullen's always from within right so
not always but like most of their scenes
you'll see that camera is in between the
actors instead of you know that sort of
Run and Gun documentary over the
shoulder style so yeah yeah it's all
very inside but you have a favorite of
those like ways would you rather be out
in the jungle again do you like the
mockumentary so I do like the
mockumentary style I do like being
outdoors I would love to shoot something
Outdoors again I remember I mean so my
the other operator who became the DP on
the office Matt Stone and I we met on
eco Challenge and and Survivor so and I
remember there was one episode we were
going to
film out in the woods it was it was like
you know we're both looking through our
Adventure Gear you know putting figure
out what pants and they were all old
packed away and they all back in the
cupboard with dusting it out often yeah
still good man they were good
[Music]
guys and Meg what are you doing October
8th uh I don't really I don't even know
what day of the week it is it's a Sunday
because you know what the birds are Back
in Town oh Philly plays the Rams at Sofi
that afternoon that's in Los Angeles so
you know I'll be there obviously we're
all going right well yeah when are you
buying tickets I gotta check with Mary
Elizabeth make sure we're free that day
when are you getting tickets yeah you
guys know that there's no need anymore
to make these kinds of plans months and
months in advance I mean we can always
just come back for tickets on game time
wait what you guys don't know game time
gametime.cl gametime.com that's the one
yeah it's the fast and easy way to buy
tickets for all the hottest sports music
comedy and theater shows near you I know
what you're talking about yes I've
always had great luck scooping up last
minute tickets with them they're very
very good yeah they're awesome and they
got that best price guarantee baby you
know we can focus on more important
matters at hand like planning our
pregame that's something I call Green
Man okay I'm looking through uh
gametime.com right now and it looks like
uh there's tons of great Flash Deals I
mean there's even uh views of the seats
and protection against event
cancellation yeah plus you know if you
find tickets in the same section or Row
for Less they'll credit you 110 percent
of the difference basically you
need money to go see Hertz and the boys
you know what I mean download the game
time app create an account and use Sunny
for twenty dollars off your first
purchase download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price guaranteed
that's Gametime dot co uh look terms
apply again create an account and redeem
code Sunny for twenty dollars off
you guys what do you think of when you
think of the sound when you hear King oh
like the money tree and it and it Chings
money come money come to me
yes okay yeah Charlie I I think of a
cash register because I'm not up on my
wall Street Mother Goose or whatever no
I was just saying money me money me
money man making now it's fine it's all
that I get okay that I get but listen
both of you are right okay so don't
worry about that all right it's it's it
is the sound of someone making their
first sale yeah on Shopify Shopify that
is the Commerce platform revolutionizing
millions of businesses worldwide yeah do
you guys know that the sunny podcast
website is actually built on Shopify uh
that's true because Shopify simplifies
selling online and in person so you can
focus on successfully growing your
business whether according to this copy
you're selling succulents or stilettos
yeah what I want to know about is
selling succulents and stilettos who's
in the middle of that Venn diagram well
that's right it covers every sales
Channel okay from an in-person POS
system uh to an all-in-one e-commerce
platform oh yeah yeah it even lets you
sell across social media markets like
Tick Tock Facebook and Instagram yeah we
sell Sunny podcast merch on Shopify and
let me tell you it really helped us move
those creep pins and keep our books in
order so we're not drowning in
accounting yeah and it's packed with
industry-leading tools to ignite growth
so you can level up your Biz without
having to learn any coding or design
skills yourself not to mention they have
24 7 help and an extensive Business
course Library so they're there to
support your success every step of the
way whether those steps earn heels are
not okay this is possibility powered by
Shopify so now it is your turn to get
serious about selling and try Shopify
today sign up for a one dollar per month
trial period one dollar per month
yeah you go to shopify.com Sunny all
lower case go to shopify.com Sunny to
take your business to the next level
today
shopify.com sunny
[Music]
foreign
you've got a lot of the office under
your belt and you get a call to try this
other show Woody did you see a few
episodes before you come in yeah and
then because sorry you had only in terms
of scripted television I think if I'm
not mistaken you had only done the
office yeah before you came and did yep
Sunny with us but you know I directed I
think at that point I probably would
have directed right couldn't like 16 of
them at that point I would have been
like you know six of them yeah and I
remember like I I I I knew I wanted to
move away from
dping and start directing more and uh
Greg Daniels let me go
do other shows and still come back and
be the DP that's cool I got I didn't
have to well who the hell does that I
remember in our first meeting one of the
things that struck me about you was
there was this there was a confidence
and an ambition that was there that I
that I found I was faking that yeah my
name
were you really yeah I don't you don't
strike me as someone who's who is Faking
It you strike me is a genuinely
confident person when it comes to your
work I am confident yeah yeah whether
it's foolhardy or not I am but I think
that's what it is right quietly
confident for no apparent reason maybe
that's the adventure background right
like there's a little bit you need a
bear in the woods you gotta act like
you're the bigger Bear yeah even if
you're not yeah yeah yeah or you know
when you're skiing down a mountain yeah
and you're going at a speed that where
you're just you're just maintaining
control but you're also right on the
edge of of catastrophic failure and
um you know you you just sort of learn a
little bit that like you can do it right
sometimes you gotta sometimes you can't
you don't need to always overthink it
first you need to like jump into it
thrust yourself into it figure it out
have fun you know and then just trust
that it'll be there when you need it so
my only real formal training is is raft
guiding and and River rescue like I I I
and I think that you know guiding a raft
down a river
and Ford paddle you don't really want to
call Ford pedal like a question yeah you
wanna you wanna you know you want to go
with confidence and you need to be
confident and direct and to call that
type of thing out so I think I had that
that type of training of trying to get
people to do things that they weren't
necessarily comfortable with yeah yeah
yeah that that is a skill I suppose I
still
hmm yeah yeah I mean you certainly
possessed it at the time I mean like I
said I think you you pushed Us in ways
that other directors hadn't quite pushed
us and you did it with a certain
confidence and enthusiasm that was you
know seductive to us I think did we have
a meeting before or did or did we just
hire you no we had a meeting we did we
had to be I remember yeah it was it was
the first season that we had uh shot on
the fox lot
um and I believe in the three of us
shared
um that corner office yeah on the third
floor third floor yeah and um yeah yeah
and we met in that office I think is
that is that do you guys do you remember
yes I did I do and I remember I remember
the conversation and it was a lot of
exactly what you led with which is I
think what you guys are doing is really
interesting but you can go further and
we were so used to meeting with
directors especially early on who would
say you can't really do that that
blocking won't work you won't hit the
light uh that and yeah I was like why
the show looks like [__] is so who cares
and we're just trying to capture what
the actors are doing and you came in and
said yeah yeah forget all you didn't
care about any of that you didn't care
about it you didn't care about any of
this stuff that we didn't care about and
I think we really liked it I'm now
remembering this relating yeah yeah we
were like that's right you know people
get caught up on this and they really
and you were you were on the same page
as us you were like that because no one
had spoken to us like that about the
show yeah
um it's it's interviewing one-on-one you
come into the room where the where the
bosses are and you're like everything
you guys are doing
come in and I'm gonna
versions of what you already are which
is great to be clear
wow this guy wow this guy's really smart
this guy's a really good director
there's something about this guy that I
like I don't know what it is I remember
shackman's interview and it was totally
different right like you know he was
like nah I like to work this way and I
would probably do things my way you know
we're like well that's interesting too
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know but also
also with the with the same degree of
confidence in himself that allowed us to
kind of give over to that but that's the
big thing like do you have a vision do
you have a a vision that is your own and
does it gel with ours you know because
you could come in and be like
the whole thing is going to be lit
brighter and you know done I mean to me
like as a director of forum follows
function that's why the office looks
like the office and you know Fargo look
like Fargo and Wilfred looked like
Wilfred it's it it wants to serve the
material and the material was you all it
was with all these characters and and it
didn't matter if how it was lit it just
had to be funny and everybody you know I
I think there's so much preciousness to
filmmaking that filmmaking often gets in
the way of filmmaking yeah I think
that's true certainly on a show like
this yeah yeah but and also you came in
and we liked you and people disregard
that sometimes when they think about
like how to prepare for an interview or
to come into a new position well I just
have to be technically good but the
truth is you're spending a lot of time
with the people that you're working with
and you just seem fun and affable in
game and the kind of person we would
want to spend time with and that goes a
long way and we knew we would have fun
with you and we did it's it's true
though it's like you going in to shoot a
show I'm going to spend more time with
the actors than I am awake with my wife
right you know yeah during that short
intense period yeah what was your
impression of us we were like these guys
were younger than I thought or were you
were like were you thinking like God
[Music]
Did you sort of feel like these guys
know what they want and I'm gonna stay
out of their way or was it like oh these
guys are lost they need some guidance no
these guys definitely know what they
want I should be here to make it even
better than what they want yeah I mean
that's why I think a director's job is
is to make it better than you know the
way that it's written or the way make it
as best as it can you know be performed
I think it's I think the director's job
is just serving the material so coming
in and I'm in charge it's like yeah
you're not really it's part of a bigger
thing you've got something going on yeah
but I mean remember meeting you all is
like there's three of you so like just
or four or five of you and you're all
you're all on all the time and it's
really really fun
um but it's also it's kind of
challenging when you're you're the new
person you're coming in to talk to the
three people who have been there through
all of it you just need to make sure
that what you think is
right yeah and that you have a way of
backing it up because
you know just the numbers of it I need
to convince three people that yeah this
is the way to do it I remember there's
one shot I was doing on
um wrestling for the troops that was
coming out of a mirror yes I remember so
many conversations about that and I
remember we did I just yeah we're in our
grandma costumes in the bird costumes
yeah yeah it's very very cool bird
costumes with a stenciled ABS as well
yes nice touch just coming out of the
mirror and you all weren't certain you
wanted to do it yeah and so I shot it
and I showed it to you go yeah let's go
do that that's cool yeah yeah you would
pitch stuff but you were never precious
about it like you know you would pitch
things that you felt felt like would
work and would maybe make the scene
funnier or whatever and you know
sometimes we would say no we were like
no that's I think I think this is
funnier and it never it never sapped you
of your confidence it never stopped you
from continuing to pitch stuff I could
try the whole way home
sure sure from that now did it was Danny
rough on you in the beginning that Danny
can sometimes test a new director I
don't know I think he can smell the
people that he can do that with yeah
he's like I'm gonna see you know if you
like like if you're worth if you're
worth my trouble here like you're like
and if you feel like if you need to be
able to take some [__] like can you take
me can you take my [__] yeah not in a
not in a mean way but like he's playing
yeah he's playing yeah maybe it's Frank
Reynolds thing but like if you say ah
Dan I think maybe you'd be in this chair
like oh really you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah you push it yeah but he didn't he
didn't give any any of the business I
mean maybe a little bit but I think he
gets to do that he's Danny DeVito I'm
sure oh yeah so it's like he's doing it
all good fun yeah but I think it could
be an intimidating thing coming to the
show and be like ah standard DeVito I
need to tell him to stand over here
you know in this when we first hired
Danny and you know we would be like I
gotta go give Danny DeVito a note that's
crazy that's insane like I can't you
know yeah that is how do you do that
crazy yeah how do you give Danny DeVito
an acting though yeah like now Danny I I
I
because he's such a legend it is kind of
intimidating doing that you know I mean
but often oftentimes I always find that
like the best Note is the note you don't
give you just go again and they give
themselves the note so by the time I'm
coming with a node I really believe it
like the best notes I ever gave Edie
Falco were the ones I never gave her you
know I remember I remember just learning
just shut up Brandon just let her she'll
feel it yeah but juggling of
personalities right this is crazy it is
I think I think every actor needs
something different and that's you know
recognizing what everybody needs is part
of a you know you should figure that out
really really quickly before you start
working with people well I think the
good thing is like the three of us we
like to get in and get out yeah so like
my my feeling you know what I mean if I
don't have to be there all day like if
you're like turn the light on with your
left hand I'll be like I'm gonna figure
out how to turn off my left hand because
I don't have a whole the whole [__]
conversation about it otherwise this is
a 10-minute conversation about whether I
should turn on with this hand but it's
not because you don't care or like when
we're there we give a hundred percent we
just have done this long enough to know
that giving 100 for five hours versus
eight hours is not going to yield a
tremendous amount of difference so let's
do it for five hours instead of it well
you learn you learn to pick your battles
right you're like this this is not
something like I can figure this out
like I don't need to turn make it into a
whole thing or a 10 minute conversation
about something you know but but then
every once in a while you do
you're like I work with Donald
Sutherland one time and he was
incredible he's he's one of my favorite
actors like of the 70s and 80s and um
and he was one of those guys that comes
from the old school and I he just had to
to deliver a very simple line and the
director came in and gave him a it was
Chapman actually that and gave him a
note and Donald wanted to talk about it
for for I mean 45 minutes and it was
just a simple thing and Matt realized
okay he stepped in it now he's going to
go and we shut down everything and
Donald talked about it for 45 minutes
then he came back and he said okay I
feel good and he did the line it was
exactly the same exactly the same and we
and he we looked at it in post
the same line delivered the same way but
Donald felt differently about it and
Jacqueline and I talked about it we
realized like what's important here is
not that we yeah so you could go back
and prove and act her wrong and say look
don't you see it's the same guy but the
fact that he felt better
made him better throughout the rest of
the day and sometimes catering to the
emotional needs on an individual basis
of somebody who's supposed to come in
and emote and be vulnerable and but just
by Nature be artistic and somewhat
difficult is part of the gig I mean what
you all do is putting yourself out there
in a very very open way you're fully
exposed so no matter what it takes you
need to make that actor feel comfortable
that they're not standing there with
anything on their face or doing
something that's not true to their
character or just feels unnatural
everybody needs something different it's
good you're a problem solver I think
also like I think you approach things
from the standpoint of like
I think it's easy to get stuck in like
this is this is what I want this is what
I want to do and if you can't get
somebody to do it you get frustrated you
could get frustrated about it but I
never sensed you getting frustrated with
us even when we did get into
conversations about things where we were
battling it out about how a certain
thing should be shot right and we
disagreed with you you are quite
unflappable and we are very frustrating
yes very frustrating when you um you
know pitch these things to them like uh
coming out of a mirror is that something
that you think about in prep or do you
show up on the day and you see a mirror
and you go hey I think we could do
something no we we placed that mirror
there okay um because I knew I wanted to
do that shot I I have I have every
single shot worked out well in advance I
do these overhead schematics that shows
where people's uh nose is going to be
pointed wow so it's just a circle with a
round thing on it oh I remember you did
these I remember looking at these yeah
and you might have a red circle with a
nose red nose and you might green so all
the characters I can I know where
they're looking who they're talking to
and where the cameras are
um I'm not very smart so I have to have
a plan and by doing that by the time I
get there I'm going to have the meat and
potatoes yeah it's just everything we
fails figure out on the day is gravy but
sometimes people that get really locked
into those things and then they come in
and the actors go I don't want to stand
there I don't want to do they freak out
because they have their whole plan for
the day so but it must be your reality
background too that lets you be pretty
adaptable even with your plans yeah I
mean I I called I I usually say I have a
theory about people standing yeah that's
right um saying things that's great and
it's only a theory until you put it on
his feet and then it could have been you
discover whether it's just a stupid idea
or not
guys I gotta pee see I told this is
what they need to feel safe is the
ability to come whenever they want to
and that's uh I think it's an important
study in male aging
[Applause]
we are all familiar with economic
uncertainty these days right oh yeah our
Stock's going up are they are they going
down what are they doing you know are we
all good again or are we headed right
back into a major collapse yeah and that
uncertainty it bleeds into every aspect
of business especially trying to find
people you mean like trying to find
people to take over a timeshare finding
people to get got uh no I just I'm
talking about like just hiring people
like you kind of hire people oh [__]
that's what I'm saying right and I'm
also what I'm saying is and it's more
important than ever to hire the right
people faster more efficiently to keep
costs down that's where zip recruiter
comes in it's a platform that
streamlines hiring and helps you find
the most qualified candidates from
pricing to technology everything that
zip recruiter does is for you and what
works best for you and right now you can
try them for free at ziprecruiter.com
Sunny yeah we used it to hire an ad
salesperson for our team and what I
really liked is how straightforward the
pricing was so you always know what
you're paying before you post it you
know helped us stick to our budget yeah
also I know that zip recruiter is also
known for you know their own smart
technology which sends your post to over
a hundred job sites and identifies the
best matches for your position yeah I'm
telling you it's the only way to find
the right people for the job right now
Ken zip recruiter uh find people to buy
our timeshare no you're never going to
sell it can zip recruiter buy our
timeshare no okay you guys got scammed
just deal with it accept it okay hire
the best with the help of a partner
who's All About You zip recruiter four
out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day just go to this
exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
sunny again that's ziprecruiter.com
s-u-n-n-y ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire
speaking to your unflappable nature you
know to this business and succeeding in
this business
is so much uh just putting yourself out
there and it's mostly rejection you know
every now and then
you you get a breakthrough every now and
then you get a show that is a hit and
you hang on for dear life and do 16
seasons of it or you know every now and
then you break through but mostly it's a
lot of lumps
you don't strike me as someone who gets
affected by the lumps and if you have
had the lumps I'm curious what they even
are like have you had the ups and downs
with this business or are you just going
down the river and uh I am I am going
down the river
um
and you know I I think it's it's I have
had definitely had had lumps and you
just can't let that lump make you
unhappy I mean what is it lump for you
though like it's like getting
have you been like fired off working on
a show or have you been like yeah
yeah that's a lump you know it makes you
you really start doubting yourself and
questioning yourself and was it
something I did how I could have done it
differently and of course the answer is
no I was perfect they were all wrong
well that's actually right like the the
answer is they wanted something you were
offering something else and that's what
and then you move on to the next but
it's like you know I mean at the end of
the day it's just television nobody's
gonna die I think that is also something
that comes from Expedition work is that
oh a light fell down oh it's raining ah
it's too windy we can't shoot it's like
nobody's gonna die and everybody's gonna
eat yeah and we're gonna sleep in a bed
which is dry have you ever been in a
situation while shooting where you're
like somebody might die right now like
when you were skiing or like doing these
Adventure treks has it ever gotten hairy
yeah yeah yeah for sure I must have been
scared to be like am I gonna film my own
death right now yeah no it's usually I
don't think it's gonna
I have this thing where I never think
it's going to be me
it's never going to be me until yeah I'm
laying there in a crumpled mess oh wow
now what about advice for young aspiring
directors like someone who who wants to
be the next random line horn you know I
think like directing television is is a
going going around and being an episodic
director
understanding that it's not your show is
the biggest thing and and the most
liberating thing that when you get there
if you don't want to do it the way that
I saw it that's cool I'm just a guest
yeah um so I think really having having
the confidence to
know what you want but also be happy
in you know not necessarily getting what
you want but getting what the show needs
I've heard it described as you're like
the babysitter you're not the parent so
if the parents have decided that this
child is being raised raised vegetarian
it's not your job to come in and serve
the kid Burgers you know yeah usually on
TV shows there's always somebody there
behind you yeah which right yeah is why
I tend to not do much episodic guest
directing anymore it's because I I
I'm I'm happy to collaborate I really
enjoy it but it's also really nice for
me to know when I've got it I just got
it and I'm done yeah um you know when
you directed the pilot of the mick yeah
and and uh many episodes as well yeah of
the mech so you was you were you were
there to establish the look so talk
about that for a second because that's a
different situation because if you if
you're going and shooting a pilot of an
episode yeah you you have a lot more
agency over how this show is produced
how it's shot how it looks can you talk
about that process a little bit but yeah
just episodic directly yeah episodic I
mean you're serving the pre-established
material and directing a pilot you're
actually
establishing what that pilot the tone
will be the look of it the you know how
it Finds Its humor or its you know
pathos whatever and so I I love
directing Pilots because it's such a
ground up building situation that you
you are creating a foundation for the
show to go for hopefully many many
seasons yeah you know I'm a dollar
memory right you directed the pilot of
that what did you drive into that yes oh
I didn't know you directed The Pilot now
so that means you've done three
different shows shot uh that are
supposed to take place in Pennsylvania
right the office Abbott Elementary and
this one yeah we went back to for the
finale of Abbott um we went to Philly
and I was great I went out there
scouting it on my own and I just hopped
on a bike and just rode everywhere yeah
that's funny it was really cool riding
over to West Philly and all of a sudden
the streets get really really shitty
yeah I would advise against the riding
of the bike did you hop on a raft and
get down to scoop
so we were trying to remember uh oh yeah
we shot uh the World Series defense and
we shot the stuff with the Philly
frenetic with him getting in the fight
with the Philly fanatic yeah
you know and and us and me bruised and
battered and then we do the red eye bit
or whatever it was right before we go
the Holiday Inn
um and in the background there is an
actual game being played and we were
trying to figure out if the stadium was
full because we put in some CGI to make
it look like it was full or if there was
an actual well here's the big mystery
too because the first scenes the
Stadium's clearly empty and it's as if
we're we've gotten there early and the
later scenes it's now full and we're
talking you know as scripted that the
game has begun but knowing our shooting
schedule we'd be like we wouldn't have
been there for hours and hours and hours
and hours an hour like uh 15 hours at
that location
so what do we do I think we shot it I
think we shot that over a couple days uh
I think we we wanted we wanted to be
empty so we oh and then we wanted it to
be full so we actually came back and
made it full are you sure we did that or
did we time it in such a way I think
either was split up over a couple days
but either way this was not CGI this was
no that was okay that's not CGI nice and
we just timed it that way because either
we timed it that way by splitting it up
every couple days or just scheduling it
that way does this look like a show that
would use CGI
but we did we did with you we did a big
CGI thing with the uh the gang Red
Knight reignites the Rivalry yeah with
the writing and fire also the oh yeah
remember that was like one of the
biggest CGI things we had ever done and
also the Flyers also the hockey the
hockey oh boy yeah no that was probably
even that was much bigger yeah much
bigger that was crazy stupid trench coat
yeah
should we watch some uh I've got tons of
uh Randall Clips so um maybe the
question is do you have a specific scene
you are you remember really loving how
it turned out from the show or anywhere
you'd like to start I mean I you know
gang rest you know for the troops I
thought was a really good episode yeah
and I remember that was like I remember
that we finished the fight scene where
Danny crashes the uh the chair over
sweet D yeah and I think I did the most
setups I've ever done and one day you
did like 50 something I think it was it
was like 90. yeah you know I think it
was like 90 cents one day I remember I
remember this and it was like a lot of
pages too like the amount of pages I
think you also had the record for pages
in a day yeah we had one day where we
shot like 12 Pages
my greatest asset is not knowing any
better and my greatest motivator is
really wanting to go home
yeah it's my big motivator I remember
the boat episode the P Diddy boat dance
being uh oh my God Caitlyn dancing with
the and didn't did we actually light
that boat on fire like no that was the
CGS that was CGI right yeah but you
remember we also with that boat we took
an old old crummy boat which is exactly
what we wanted yeah and then they made
it look older and it just then it looked
more like a set yeah it made it look
yeah we were upset
why did you have to make it look old
Long Beach right so we're down in the
Long Beach right and I actually swam in
there that filthy filthy water
we had to hide Caitlyn's pregnancy for
the first half of the Season we had to
take a boat out to the boat
yep
and where were you
also have a boat that you were filming
from I think we were filming from a
barge that was uh like a flat pontoon
boat yeah yeah
yes
endangered species are delicious Charlie
did you guys ever find those keys well
they're endangered we did actually I did
in the orange roughy for instance
and get the hell out of there because uh
we're gonna be bringing back a couple of
tasty treats if you know what I'm saying
hey man yeah absolutely I'll get right
on that that's how you patronize someone
right there what
what don't worry about it man hey scoop
equipment's broken it's useless what the
hell with it let's get back to shrimping
I don't toss this [__] it's crap anyway
ah
that's that was not CJ
that was real oh yeah yeah yeah flame
bars the boat is on fire what do you
mean
where'd we shoot that we shot that fire
shot on the lock right I think so yeah I
think we shot that on a lot and then we
just have a lighting effect on the
window there yeah I think we had to
shoot that actually outside and take
some of that set outside really yeah I
think so because you can't you can't
light something on fire in sets that's
right
so much more romantic in the middle of
nowhere where we can be completely alone
decisions based on fear right Dennis
yeah
no more Diddy boats damn catfish
sniffing in my heels all the way
endangered my ass
happened
the hell of a swim Charlie where's the
boat what happened to the boat
that's right well yeah how would we not
see that
that is CG
it's not
yeah
how do we see the the thing about your
Lighting on fire is really funny
how do we make it sink yeah CG some kind
of some computer you know Fanatics maybe
we sunk something
well
did having Randall on the season five
inspire you to be like oh maybe we could
do a whole thing on a boat like just in
terms of you they talk about how you
brought scale to the show and like kind
of made you think you could write things
assuming that we were going to find the
way to shoot them where you couldn't
actually see like so we would have
written the hockey thing assuming well
we won't actually like see the stadium
or we would have written that being like
well you might not actually see like the
boat sank he might you know so you were
the one I think saying no there's
the world has changed we can like
there's technology yeah and that that
you don't have to spend a billion
dollars to do it yeah I mean I don't
remember how we sunk the boat but I I
think it was just you know took a plate
of it and just you know shot it so that
it was you know a thing that you could
manipulate on its own and uh yeah
explain a plate to the general audience
so you know innate sometimes you're
shooting a something on a green screen
where you can isolate the the character
or the element that you want to isolate
and lift it off the background and put
it onto another background another plate
so that's what I'm sure we did is we
just shot that as a plate shot 15
seconds of it and then it was isolated
and manipulated and it was its own layer
now here we weren't allowed to like go
to a game and film at a game which was
our first request
but we were allowed to film a game we
you know we weren't allowed to like get
on the ice and do the whole like
scene which would take a lot of time but
so that shot these are stun stunt guys
in Philly
um
that's awesome that's awesome
yeah yeah
now that's real
and that was real well that that's all
I remember not feeling like it's pretty
good I remember feeling upset that the
stunt guys were doing uh the stunt guy
for me was like doing bad skating I'm
like hey man
Charlie Kelly it's good
yeah this all was so much crazy sounds
great now yeah
snapzone
but you kind of also can't tell I mean
it's pretty dark here
uh yeah the choice to explode that was a
lot of fun
[Applause]
Philly sports legends I remember the
shot it pans over to
a tight shot right
no right here Mac Mac so that's the
state so you must have sent them a shot
list yeah
laughs
like that and that's a rink somewhere in
Burbank yeah we must have gone there and
shot that Mac you you went to Philly
yeah you went to Philly
yeah I mean I remember okay so that
wasn't just a second unit director I
think I think I thought I remember yes
that stuff because I remember yeah the
board moving in the background so you
must have gone yeah with with a unit did
we did we shoot in Philly in season six
is there some Seasons we should have
shot there and some we haven't uh well I
think it wasn't hockey season by the
time we were filming so like you must
have gone earlier like while we were
yeah I don't know I just went I just did
uh I'm sure you'd get on the you'd be
able to go there now right now we could
yeah now I bet we could work it out but
you know they're not like hey it's a
game there's a team We're not gonna like
you know the the fans are there to for a
game not for you guys to film a scene
for eight hours on the ice so I went and
shot basketball for It's Always Sunny uh
for Abbott Elementary and it you know I
had four minutes and you know it's
you're part of some a much much bigger
thing and it's it's clear how little you
matter to them it's like okay you're off
you're done you got your four minutes I
was I need one more no yeah
running a two billion dollar franchise
nobody cares about your little show it's
like whenever you shoot on the universal
uh you shoot on one of the lots and and
all of a sudden you just hear like a
ding ding ding ding and you hear like
some like trainer over here they're
shooting and then you look up and it's a
tram car that's coming through we're
shooting we're shooting here and they're
like yeah no we don't care we make more
money off the park the park it makes way
more money get out of the way we'll run
you the [__] over here [__] they do not
care the people in the car would love to
see that actually but yeah first of all
they're like what show is this we've
never heard of we've never heard of this
um another thing you shot was the Kitten
Mittens commercial oh yeah do you have
any memories of uh
yeah I remember you know I remember to
get the cat to walk funky we we you know
trained with a cat put some um
like corn or something and it's in in
the mittens so the cat oh so that it was
uncomfortable it was like walking really
really funny I thought it was just doing
that because the mittens were on yeah
there's something in there I don't
remember what it was right I like the
idea of it being corner
cut that cut that yeah you get a call
from Peter yeah
you made the cat walk on corn
yeah yeah dare you you got to eat the
corn afterwards okay sure sure and then
we got to eat the cat it's all it's a
natural natural cycle of you know it's
totally Humane uh so are you still
directing Abbott Elementary I will be
yes okay so I stayed on I stayed on I
did the pilot and I directed the first
are you eping as well yeah okay so I EP
that so you're heavily involved in that
one heavily involved in that one it's a
big hit yeah now what if we said we
wanted to have you back to direct more
episodes If It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia at some point can we afford
you I'd love to yeah we can at this
point but we can try I'll take scale
will you take scale will you still allow
us yeah you know completely steamroll
you yeah yeah when you come in I think
that's that's my forte okay give up with
what you want yeah cry on the way home
process it later it's about your house
at all wait we have to talk about your
house for a second because you you are
one of the true first like California
hippies that I've that I that I whose
compounds I'd ever been to yeah he I
don't know if you still live there but
he lives he lived up in the hills of
Topanga Canyon
um and any stalkers out there just know
if you try to find him Topanga county is
massive yeah and you'll never find you
will die out in the woods it's this old
uh ashram where Buddhist monks used to
live back in the 60s and 70s so some
weird [__] was going oh yeah because the
transitioned from Buddhism to mansonism
possibly yeah yeah a little bit of
overlap a little bit of overlap yeah
sure a lot of meditation but a lot of
drugs a lot of drugs a lot of yeah peace
and love peace
I was in an orgy your house
that's cool yeah that's very cool but
you also have lots of animals yeah and
the very first time I had ever been on a
horse so he he I don't know if you still
keep horses but I had horses up there
and you're like let's just go riding on
a horse I was like okay I've never been
on a horse before and you're like it's
fine it's easy it's easy so I go okay so
and I'm just following you oh [__] and
all of them so we're just going down
this Trail and I'm like what the [__]
okay this is fun this is fun I'm having
fun
and then a deer comes out and the horse
gets spooked and bucks and Chucks me
into next week off the horse in like
these like grass slash wheat Fields oh
yeah yeah oh man and the horse ran away
and Randall was far away and I was just
like on the ground like I got tossable
yeah that's scary dude yeah that's
that's no joke I was laughing
hysterically the entire time I remember
like I'm calling out
rob you good
yep yep what are you doing man ah on
this bush I remember you didn't tell me
I was looking for I was like let me find
this horse
so I can like catch up with him and the
horse was not having it yeah get the
[__] away sorry about that a horse horse
scared horse yeah scared horse can I get
back I'm scared 2 000 pound Beast I'm
going to go yeah hop back on I do
remember that yeah yeah are you still in
that place yeah well riding horses still
riding horses nice
um yeah still in that place the place is
very very different it was in ashram I
bought off an 80 year old monk who was
living there with 11 disciples and he
was a renunciast and the first thing he
certainly renounced was maintenance
hit everywhere and the whole place
smelled like Patchouli and incense but
um that place is no longer we started
remodeling it and then it was like yeah
this is we ended up lowering the whole
thing it's like six inches and just
building a new house oh you did yeah
okay
I remember you were forever there were
some Spirits in there that you want to
cleanse your cleanse yeah you know good
stuff yeah some fun ones there was a guy
who came a kid came from you know a week
ago I'm down mucking the horses and this
kid came up he says hey uh do you live
here I said yeah I do he says I was born
in that bedroom I'm like really you
better come in man come come check it
out and this kid who grew up in that
house
um you know walking through the the
property and had all these memories of
yeah it was really cool yeah that is
cool that's awesome
I watched my parents [__] there yeah I
watched my my parents [__] other people
yeah you can watch and murder somebody
over there yeah
um California was a strange Place super
strange I still have a buck naked Peter
bogdanovich still wearing his Ascot uh
right here right and uh and I'll never
forget that this came up on the podcast
uh when your name was mentioned were you
aware that your last name means unicorn
in german yes you are yes yeah I brought
this up it doesn't it's unicorn sounds
better than Einhorn I don't even like
saying it yeah you know it's kind of
doesn't doesn't have a but like German
it doesn't really have an Elegance to it
so Einhorn Einhorn yeah I don't know
that's pretty cool that's a good it's
like a memorable name and see as magical
as unicorn though no it's not it's my
family crest you know is it you know
it's a unicorn
but my company my company name is sad
unicorn sad unicorn that's nice because
there's nothing funnier than a sad
unicorn yeah is there such a thing it's
a sad unicorn well they're all sad right
because they know they're off one horn
yeah
most other beasts have too yeah
well this is this is me thing other than
sad we've loved having you on it's been
wonderful yeah man
we definitely can't afford you anymore
but we'd love to I would love to come
play great you would oh yeah it was
absolutely always a giggle I would love
to have you back you know yeah I always
had a giggle it was always fun yeah
remember sweet D stuck to the floor in
the movie
yeah how miserable that was she was fine
though she was like like this game
literally glued to the floor yeah yeah
well thanks Randall yeah thank you thank
you good to see you great to see you bud
that's it
foreign